bon sens sur le mardi 6 octobre merci de
nous retrouver pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 le journal on commence
tout de suite avec les titres de votre
actualité locale signature ce matin à
saint quentin en yvelines en présence du
ministre patrick kanner du contrat de
ville intercommunale son objectif
principal concentrer les efforts auprès
des populations aux plus faibles revenus
il vit une information jeunesse lance
une semaine dédiée à l'égalité
filles-garçons la préfecture des
yvelines se mobilisent autour du projet
sud yvelines à terre des great et nous
parlerons de ces deux associations avec
nos invités en plateau et enfin
l'établissement d'hébergement pour
personnes âgées dépendantes va bientôt
voir le jour à montigny le bretonneux
alors qu'une réunion d'information se
tiendra jeudi soir dans la commune nous
faisons le point sur ce dossier
visite ministérielle patrice patrick
kanner ministre de la ville était ce
matin à saint quentin en yvelines pour
la signature du contrat de ville
accompagnés d'élus locaux il s'est rendu
à trappes ainsi qu'à la ville de la
verrière pour constater les chantiers
réalisés et les projets à venir
williams elle était sur place et la
suite pour nous faire regarder le
contrat de ville a été signé ce matin au
siège de la communauté d'agglomération
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines en présence
de patrick kanner ministre de la ville
l'objectif fédérer l'ensemble des
partenaires institutionnels économiques
et associatifs en inscrivant leurs
actions dans un document unique
l'objectif énoncé mobiliser les moyens
de l'état naturellement les moyens
permettant notamment secteur associatif
de pouvoir se développer et être utile
notamment à la vie quotidienne des
habitants
le contrat de ville c'est le moyen de
rétablir l'égalité donner plus à ceux
qui ont moins
c'est une politique publique qui est
très noble parce que ça signifie qu'on
ne laisse personne sur le bord du chemin
mobiliser l'ensemble des politiques
publiques de droit commun pour rétablir
l'égalité d'accès des services pour les
habitants des quartiers prioritaires des
retombées qui impacterait directement 31
mille personnes dans la communauté
d'agglomération je pense que il est
important que de l'argent public venant
de différents partenaires puissent être
mis en place va puisse servir à la
nouvelle dimension des territoires que
nous souhaitons c'est à dire on veut
plus avoir de quartiers défavorisés
on veut niveler par le haut avant cette
signature le ministre a visité deux
quartiers dits défavorisés
d'abord celui du bois de l'étang à la
verrière pu constater les chantiers et
les projets à venir
avant de se rendre à trappes dans le
quartier des modifiés pour nous c'est
évidemment le renouvellement urbain
c'est à dire la possibilité dans ce
quartier de lui faire bénéficier d'une
opération un peu plus lourd de
construction rénovation parce que
l'ambition elle est écrite mais il faut
qu'elle soit accompagnée des moyens
financiers pour l'instant nous n'avons
pas de visibilité sur ses moyens
financiers que je fais des crédits
spécifiques ou des crédits droit commun
ce contrat d'une durée de cinq ans
apporterait des subventions en baisse
comparé aux précédents une cartographie
financières devraient être mises en
place d'ici le mois de janvier pour
évaluer le montant des crédits la page
l'association pour adultes et jeunes
handicapés des yvelines fête cette année
ses 40 ans pour l'occasion l'association
organisé un grand événement festif ce
mardi au théâtre espace coluche de
plaisir fanny bourdillon et camille
lambert la page des yvelines fête ses 40
ans l'association accompagne adultes et
jeunes handicapés
quarante ans de vie associative intense
avec aujourd'hui vingt établissements
dans le département pouvant accueillir
700 personnes parmi elles deux sont 13
enfants dont la plupart sont scolarisés
nous travaillons hors les murs ça veut
dire que nous allons voir le jeune là où
il est sur son lieu de vie scolaire
notre objectif est de rendre les jeunes
plus autonomes bien sûr dans les
apprentissages scolaires mais aussi dans
sa vie quotidienne
marilyn a attendu sept ans pour qu'une
place se libère pour sa fille hélène
aujourd'hui elle est très satisfaite de
la prise en charge de la page une prise
en charge non seulement du handicap
délais mais surtout de ses potentialités
et lui donner un espace pour s'exprimer
et pratiquer des activités avoir une vie
sociale rencontrer des gens pas vivre
seulement au sein du foyer mais sortir
faire des choses animations et tables
rondes ont rythmé cette journée
anniversaire
l'occasion aussi de faire le point sur
les projets à venir cet après midi c'est
donc la caf table ronde sur les aidants
là nous avons un gros travail à faire on
a aussi derrière des parents qui peuvent
être en souffrance qui ont besoin de
temps en temps j'allais dire de prendre
la haine pouvoir respirer vous pouvoir
avoir des moments mais c'est sa
politique on essaie de mettre en place
ce qu'on appelle du lait nous aidera
dans les mois à venir
l'association mettra aussi la priorité
sur le vieillissement des personnes
handicapées et la situation des enfants
autistes
il est temps de parler égalité hommes
femmes avec nos invités en plateau avec
nous bouffe leur avocate medan alors
lucile guérin vous êtes informatrice au
sein à dives une information jeunesse
vous êtes venu avec charles manso qui
est lycéenne ont soir à bouffe
vous venez présenter la semaine égalité
fille garçon et à ma droite nous avons
amanites omar chargé de mission pour le
projet sud-yvelines terre d'égalité et
marielle salina déléguée départementale
aux droits des femmes et à l'égalité
nous parlerons avec vous des gagnants
d'un nouveau projet sud immunitaire
d'égalité un projet pluri partenariale
pour vaso pour valoriser par dont le
rôle et l'action des femmes sur le
territoire de l'arrondissement de
rambouillet la thématique générale donc
la promotion de l'égalité sera déclinée
donc en plusieurs volets éducatif
culturel emploie toute l'année il me
semble si c'est bien ça et donc la
thématique de l'égalité hommes femmes
est toujours d'actualité on voit avec
ces deux projets acquis et donc qui dure
cette semaine et toute l'année 2015 et
mais avant cela nous avons a demandé
justement où saint quentinois
quel était leur avis sur cette question
je vous propose de regarder leurs
réponses je pense que
on y arrive petit à petit il n'y a
aucune raison qu'on différencie un homme
d'une femme elles ont toutes les maps
locative
comme homme et comme la femme j'en ai
aucune idée je sais que ça tend vers une
égalisation qu'il ya moins de
différences et d'inégalités cannes en
mai après les femmes elles ont quand
même des postes assez important
maintenant
donc ouais je pense que ça va dans le
bon sens ça va dans le bon sens mais il
faut être vigilant parce que rien n'est
gagné
voilà il ya toujours des on sent qu'il
ya des possibilités de retour en arrière
terrible je suis encore des inégalités
qui demeurent dans les salaires non dans
les droits dont beaucoup de choses
encore du travail à faire non mesdames
je voyais réagir justement à ces
témoignages mares elle n'a qu'en pensez
vous ça reflète pas la réalité
vous connaissez oui je pense que mon en
effet il faut être vigilant je pense que
la question de l'égalité hommes femmes
elle est partout elle est au sein de
l'entreprise aller à l'école et oui en
effet il reste encore des inégalités
persistantes mais je pense que des
actions comme information jeunesse ou
des actions que peuvent avoir les
entreprises
oui ça va dans le bon sens heureusement
mais c'est ce genre aussi de témoignages
que vous avez ce genre de réponse oui
c'est ça aussi qui nous a poussé à
répondre à l'appel à projets de la
région sur l'égalité filles garçons et à
mettre en place cette semaine dédiée à
cette thématique comme les transversales
ça nous permet de toucher plein
d'aspects mais on a fait le choix de
d'étudier le côté professionnel choix
d'orientation on aurait pu prendre
l'égalité entre hommes et femmes dans le
milieu sportif dans plein d'autres
domaines on a fait choix là mais c'est
un sujet qui nous tient à coeur est
alors justement sur sept sur sept
semaines le message que vous faire
passer c'est de faire de penser de dire
aux jeunes filles qu'elles sont égales
aux garçons et qu'elles peuvent tout
faire notamment au niveau de l'emploi ou
de voleurs perspective oui aussi voilà
il ya déjà des jeunes filles on a eu des
témoignages de par les interventions
qu'on fait dans les lycées ou dans les
écoles
certains métiers oh non ça ne semble pas
trop accessible pour une fille justement
voilà l'objectif de cette semaine c'est
de dire voilà on peut être femme
mécanicienne comme un homme peut être
sage femme or le terme est un petit peu
étrange l'employé sages femmes pour un
homme mais voilà dans les deux sens ça
marche et c'est ça qu'on veut faire
passer comme message alors charlène
bonsoir vous êtes lycéenne vous avez
justement assister à cette semaine vous
avez justement une des initiatives
ça vous semble en portant vos tanks
lycéenne de parler d'égalité homme femme
fille garçon c'est ça vous semble un
sujet proche de vous pour ceux qui ont
encore des inégalités qui persistent
oui mais pas dans tous les domaines par
exemple dans le domaine de sport par
exemple dans le célèbre jeu va s'effacer
maintenant il ya l'équipe des filles
c'est une première de cette année avant
y'avait pas donc on a pu travailler sur
l'aspect historique
donc on a révisé tout ce qui est des
dates tout ça les grandes dates
depuis quand les femmes ont eu leurs
droits plusieurs droits donc voilà est
ce que ça vous semble important d'en
parler notamment au lycée à l'école
parce qu'elle peut-être dans les cours
d'histoire des questions si on n'en
parle pas forcément justement de cette
problématique là oui je trouve ça
important ça pue ça peut changer
beaucoup de choses pour que les femmes
en plus de droits parce que aujourd'hui
aussi a encore des inégalités dans
plusieurs domaines nous emmène de
travail aussi les considérants mass
effect pas encore qu un homme soit par
exemple assistants maternels parce qu'on
a peur de la pédophilie tout ça oui
c'est important ça peut être intéressant
justement stabilité c'est aussi le
projet sur lequel vous travaillez
sud-yvelines terre d'égalité ça s'étend
sur toute l'année donc là de septembre
jusqu'à 2016 jusqu'en juin juillet c'est
ça ces cds d'où est venue cette volonté
vraiment parce que c'est une exclusivité
dans les yvelines un taux marche
contrairement à vous comment ça s'est
fait un petit peu cette décision la mise
en place du projet je pense que marielle
sera plus apte à vous répondre sur ce
sujet mais je pense que ça a été
impulsée par le ministère et par la
préfecture et que c'était vraiment une
volonté une volonté générale du
département est justement le choix des
yvelines parce que c'est pas
spécialement un département où les
inégalités sont creusées donc je ne sais
pas pourquoi vous commencent à leur
département la wii alors pourquoi ce
département parce que moi déjà je
travaille donc en fait c'est vrai que ce
qui était intéressant c'est de pouvoir
décliner sur un arrondissement dont
celui de rambouillet ça s'est fait assez
naturellement ce qu'on en fait et c'est
aussi des histoires de rencontres de
volonté de rencontre et ce territoire
c'est vrai qu'on a rencontré notamment
des partenaires impliqués volontaires
l'usiné à chapeaux à rambouillet la
maison elsa triolet aragon donc en effet
et d'autres partenaires théâtre de saint
quentin et je passe également d'autres
preuves ou projets qui sont qui sont
programmés mais c'est vrai que avant
tout c'était de faire un zoom sur ce
territoire et sur tous les projets
existants sous le prisme de l'égalité
alors justement à cette occasion la 11e
édition de festi lachance automne en
valeur la création féminine avec une
affiche spéciale c'est voilà un beau
clin d'oeil pour votre projet oui c'est
vrai qu'on s'est rendu compte et
notamment l'étude sur la
représentativité des femmes dans le
milieu culturel c'est vrai qu'on s'est
vite aperçu que dans les festivals
il a une sous-représentation des femmes
qu'elles soient metteurs en scène
chorégraphes chanteuse et c'est vrai que
cette année c'est un festival 100%
féminin en sont réjouis donc il ya
vraiment un volet une volonté de
renforcer la visibilité des femmes dans
le milieu
la culture tout à fat man et par rapport
justement avec une information jeunesse
vous aussi c'est un axe qui est
important pour vous au niveau des jeunes
oui tout à fait tous les axes nous sont
importants vu qu'on est généraliste et
on essaye de l'aborder dans plein dans
le plus d'aix possible en fait pour
faire comprendre que voilà les
inégalités entre hommes et femmes
doivent encore plus se réduire et
arrivait vraiment une égalité et
qu'elles sont un peu les clichés les
plus difficiles à combat parce que la
situation a évolué au fil de ces années
maintenant vos gouvernements que la
parité est respectée qui sont vraiment
voilà les clichés où c'est compliqué de
faire prendre conscience aux gens que
voilà l'égalité existe là aussi bas dans
l'amidon les métiers je trouve que c'est
un bon exemple
voilà il ya certains jeunes qui se passe
se lancer dans des métiers où il ya plus
on a plus tendance à avoir des femmes
pareil pour l' inverse et du coup voilà
notre rôle il est là il est là aussi de
faire réfléchir les jeunes sur ces
questions là et puis les encourager à
dépasser ses préjugés en fait c'est un
travail de fond qu'il faut faire tout à
fait je pense qu'il faut vraiment
démontré que chacun a sa place dans
chaque domaine et que on est tous égaux
et que donc tout le monde peut faire ce
qu'il veut
les axes sur lesquels il faut travailler
je pense notamment à peut-être par
rapport au jeune fille ou femme
peut-être redonner à la confiance il ya
des choses comme ça soit elles font un
peu appuyé justement au sein du festival
chance automne on a
on a mis en place une rencontre avec
elle donc l'artiste qui viendra
justement pour parler de des obstacles
qu'elle a pu rencontrer dans son métier
pour vraiment communiqué et ce soir là
il y aura une classe donc qui sera
présente et qui pourra interagir durant
cette rencontre débat qui pourra poser
des questions et avoir plus
d'informations par rapport à la place
des femmes par exemple dans le milieu
musical
est-ce que charlène vous voilà en tant
qu lycéenne vous avez peut-être envie
d'avoir des témoignages de jeunes filles
de femmes qui vous de qui vous dire eh
ben voilà moi j'ai suis je suis arrivé
il faut que je fasse ça c'était quelque
chose qui manque
oui ça plus je voudrais bien avoir des
témoignages pour voir comment les femmes
ne se sont pas tus pour avoir leurs
droits tout ça ça peut être attaqué
estimant que des exemples un peu dans la
société sont vous soit société
médiatique au gouvernement on peut dire
ben une telle réussite mais aussi est
vraiment elle va me servir des ongles de
modèle pour la suite de ma carrière
non c'est vrai je suis trouvé il ya
beaucoup d'exemples par exemple ségolène
royal elle a été elle aurait pu être
présidente marine le pen est premier
ministre
en 2010 cet été sera aussi donc oui je
peux me dire que si elle est longue les
u6 d'autres femmes peuvent réussir à
être dans la politique par exemple y
voilà c'est important aussi de susciter
les vastes que la parité n'est pas très
représentée sur ce plateau il manque
bien sûr là des quartiers c'est
important susciter le débat justement
entre hommes et femmes et des choses qui
sont prévues dans ce cadre là dans la
semaine une information jeunesse tout à
fait on travaille avec des lycéens et
avec un foyer
un foyer sur versailles le débat il fait
partie justement des échanges et on voit
que c'est très intéressant est que les
jeunes n'hésitent pas parler de ce sujet
là on avait un petit peu peur et au
final on est très surpris et puis ça va
continuer jusqu'à vendredi
voilà des filles des garçons qu'elle
change sur ce sujet je pense que ça ça
construit quelque chose et c'est très
bien et c'est ce qu'on voulait justement
il ya des crises il ya aussi une
exposition et qui va peut-être amené à
la discussion vous essayez aussi de
faire intervenir les hommes justement
pour l'égalité entre hommes et femmes il
ya des actions qui leur sont destinés
principalement à l'or va principalement
sur bon pour le coup chaque action est
tout public
mais c'est vrai que ce qui est
intéressant dans des projets autour des
lycéens c'est vraiment de travailler
aussi bien envers en direction des
filles en direction des garçons et que
en effet la mixité des métiers je pense
que l'orientation scolaire aussi est
importante notamment sur l'éducation
nationale scotia d un travail à mener
les services académiques le font déjà
c'est vrai qu'il ya des projets autour
de la découverte des métiers la
découverte des métiers d'aidé à la
personne par exemple pour pour les
garçons ou où les où les femmes vers des
métiers plus de l'automobile ou autre
oui je pense qu'il ya des initiatives
intéressantes les axes sur lesquels il
faut vraiment travailler peut-être
l'emploi l'économie
saler les axes importants selon vous oui
je pense qu'il ya aussi toute la
question de l'image en fait je pense que
si la question de la publicité la
question de l'image et des stéréotypes
qui sont encore véhiculée dans des
publicités ou d'enée je pense qu'il ya
encore un travail à travailler enfin
quelque chose à faire vraiment sur la
publicité sur l'image qu'on véhicule
justement c'est un atelier que vous
aviez traités avec une information
jeunesse question est ressorti justement
là des jeunes filles
qui on a travaillé là dessus et est un
peu étonné oui de la manière dont toutes
les publicités été retouché un sacré le
débat maintenant celle la fin cette
photo là non il n'y a pas de retouche
pas si elle leur a expliqué que voilà
même minime il ya toujours une retouche
sur les images et que voilà faut en
avoir conscience et
pour aussi son choix de métier voilà
enfin c'est très important de prendre
conscience de ça donc c'est aussi une
question et médiatique vraiment
différents axes sur lesquels il faut
travailler il faut parler de ce niveau
des médias au niveau de l'école et aussi
peut-être dans ce sport et d'activités
sportives et par exemple vous avez un
rôle aussi sportif je pense vous allez
mettre des choses en avant là dessus des
rencontres peut-être fille garçon
on travaille avec justement la leaf est
donc un club de prévention d'éducation
spécialisée voilà et donc ils ont
organisé
ils ont organisé un tournoi de foot
féminin et on aimerait bien faire la
clôture du projet sud yvelines avec eux
donc mettre un projet d'exposition
photos sur justement d'effets des
footballeuses donc qui voilà qui assume
totalement le fait de pratiquer un sport
vus comme masculin voir avons parlé de
ce fifa tout à l'heure vous avez l'air
de vous donnera peut-être en foot c'est
quelque chose que vous inspire la on a
parlé notamment l'année dernière c'était
la coupe du monde féminine au canada ça
vous a au québec ça vous a j'espère
interpellé bladi on voit des filles qui
jouent au foot il ya pas seulement eux
que les bleus il ya aussi bas les bleus
est du coup c'est important pour vous de
voir aller fier de représenter dans le
sport on oui ça peut être important mais
ça me choque pas en fait parce que je
savais déjà que les filles pouvaient je
veux foot
on dit souvent que les fier je vais ça
ferait jouer au foot mais moi je suis
pas d'accord les filles ça je voudrais
maintenant les m'identifie pas c'est
intéressant même les gars cotisent y
jouit prenne l'équipe de filles
maintenant et voilà et même les femmes
peuvent pratiquer des milliers d'hommes
comme la police tous à la bac brigade
anti criminelle est ce que il ya par
lyon je sais pas peut-être des des
métiers ou auxquelles vous vous dire moi
vous vous êtes dit je ne pourrais pas le
faire parce que pour une fille c'est
trop difficile et que maintenant grâce
justement à des campagnes de publicité
ou les informations yvenat information
jeunesse ou d'autres projets mais dia bâ
finalement ça je ne savais pas gelé a
pris maintenant oui dans le domaine de
la police je me dis un an je suis
arriverait pas assis trop duré tout oui
grâce à
notre projet je me suis dit si je peux y
arriver c'est possible si plusieurs
femmes en ont réussi ou aussi je peux le
faire donc voilà il ya aussi un point
que j'aimerais aborder
malgré il ya un fort taux d'activité des
femmes donc dans les yvelines donc après
62 à 65 % des femmes travaillent contre
60 % la moyenne nationale mais plus
généralement ligne alité c'est à la fois
la cause est le résultat de la violence
sexiste par exemple en 2013 il ya eu
1384 dépôt de plainte pour violences au
sein du couple qui ont été enregistrés
dans les yvelines parler d'égalité
hommes-femmes c'est aussi un moyen de
combattre la violence faite aux femmes
quand ça vaut notamment brésiliens oui
tout à fait je pense que c'est
intéressant de se rendre compte qu'en
fait la question d'égalité la question
des violences aller intimement liés et
que déconstruire les stéréotypes parler
d'égalité c'est aussi combattre la
violence qu'on a dans notre société une
femme sur dix est victime de violences
au cours de sa vie donc c'est important
de le dire
et en effet ça fait partie de l'axé
aussi primordial de prévention de
messages aussi qu'il faut porter donc on
va là et les violences faut surtout
appeler le 39 19 ans que je fais de la
pub pour le numéro national
eh bien merci beaucoup alors je le
rappelle la semaine l'égalité filles
garçons c'est jusqu'à vendredi au centre
yves une information jeunesse à
versailles est la première initiative du
projet yvelines sud terre d'égalité
c'est le partenariat avec le festival
chance automne au féminin c'est à
l'usiné à chapeaux aux rambouillet et
c'est du 2 au 11 octobre 2015 n'hésitez
pas à vous renseigner si vous voulez
participer à ce festival
merci beaucoup mais dawn est devenu en
plateau avec moi d'avoir répondu à mon
invitation et ne manquerons pas de
suivre votre actualité siens une action
solidaire maintenant les employés d'un
groupe se mobilise
ils veulent récolter des fonds pour
sauver un de leurs collègues atteint
d'un cran ce d'un concert christophe a
besoin d'une greffe de foie
pour pouvoir continuer à vivre une
opération très coûteuse qui ne se
pratique pas en france ses collègues eux
restent déterminés à trouver des fonds
nécessaires williams elle nous en parle
pour christophe et je pense que ça lui
ferait payer
donc merci les employés d'une entreprise
de la commune de plaisir ont décidé de
s'unir pour sauver leurs collègues de
travail cela fait 28 ans et luttent
depuis un an et demi contre un sarcome
une forme de cancer
un stade très avancé il ne peut plus se
déplacer mais continue de travailler
depuis son domicile à besançon
aujourd'hui il ne reste qu'une solution
la greffe du foie donc nous avons
organisé cette manifestation ses
collègues ses amis dans le but de le
soutenir et surtout ne l'aider à
récolter des fonds pour une greffe de
foie et des soins qui aujourd'hui ne
peuvent se faire qu'à l'étranger
en france le protocole n'autorise pas la
grève pour un stade avancé comme celui
de christophe les états unis serait une
solution pour une opération seulement
voilà cent cinquante mille euros sont
nécessaires pour financer l'intervention
à ce jour nous sommes 325 personnes
avoir fait un don sur le site internet
ce qui représente en deux semaines près
de 18000 euros
il nous reste aujourd'hui à 130 euros
récoltés
il suffit que chacun d'entre nous fasse
un petit geste pour lui donner la chance
de s'en sortir c'est vrai c'est l'union
qui fait la force
en grand sportif amateur de triathlon
christophe conserve cette force et sa
rage de vivre dans son combat contre la
maladie
le combat que ses collègues ne le
laisserai pas les seuls je vais le délai
breake quelques semaines en raison de
l'état avancée de cancer
ils feront tout pour récolter cette
somme dans les jours à venir de nombreux
événements concerts tombola et
rassemblements sont prévus pour
permettre à christophe de vivre tout
simplement une course pour la bonne
cause l'association spécial olympics
france a organisé aujourd'hui à midi la
7e édition de sa course solidaire
interentreprises à montigny le
bretonneux 196 coureurs et 50
entreprises de cinquante ans olivier
cp à cet événement des enfants atteints
d'une déficience mentale ont également
participé à la course
la responsable nationale des relais
interentreprises axel dubuisson nous
présente le concept de cette course
elle est étonnée qu rodez mickaël mille
euros c'est une course solidaire l'idée
c'est que d'arriver à fédérer les
salariés la région sur sur cette cause
qu'est le handicap mental
justement vous eu lien en ayant des
athlètes c'est l'olympique ce qu'ils
sont également présents pour voilà pour
partager un petit peu le temps cette
pause déjeuner sur une boucle de 2 km 5
donc ça accessible à tous
le parcours est pas plus compliqué que
ça donc non voilà l'idée c'est vraiment
qu'il puisse participer et la ville de
montigny le bretonneux accompagne les
besoins les évolutions de ses habitants
début 2016 des travaux commenceront dans
le parc de la couleur et du château de
la ville pour accueillir un ehpad et une
résidence services seniors regardez ce
reportage de sephora namani et elodie
moines en france plus de 11 millions de
personnes n'ont plus de 65 ans face au
vieillissement de la population montigny
le bretonneux avec le soutien de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et du conseil
départemental prépare l'ouverture pour
fin 2010 est d'un ehpad un établissement
hospitalier pour personnes âgées
dépendantes dans le château et le parc
de la couldre de montigny le bretonneux
ce que nous avions souhaité c'est que
effectivement l'établissement les pattes
se trouve en coeur de ville pas loin
d'un certain nombre de deux facilités
comme
boulangerie pharmacie va des commerces
l'objectif c'était aussi de faire que
healy et disons continuité le parc va
rester ouvert en ehpad ya quand même des
personnes qui aiment bien quand même
sortir un petit peu pour voir tout en
étant accompagné depuis ils
rencontreront pas
lézignan mentale qui se promène dans
paris 88 pensionnaires pourront être
accueillis dans cet ehpad équipé d'un
pôle médical de différents services dont
balnéothérapie et d'unités spécialisées
alzheimer l'ouverture d'une résidence
seniors de 82 logements est également
prévu la résidence services et cet
espace un peu intermédiaire entre je
suis à mon domicile seul dans un
immeuble dans une maison et puis je suis
dans un établissement d'hébergement pour
personnes âgées dépendantes
jeudi 8 octobre une réunion
d'information portant sur les travaux
d'aménagement de l'ehpad et de la
résidence service est prévue à 20h30 au
club le village de montigny le
bretonneux travaux qui devraient débuter
début 2016 et avant de nous quitter je
vous propose de faire un petit détour
par versailles ce week-end le potager du
roi organiser la 22e édition de sa fête
du goût et du jardinage en partenariat
avec l'école nationale supérieure de
paysages l'occasion pour les visiteurs
de découvrir le savoir-faire des
jardiniers fanny bourdillon et william l
ce week-end vers celles organisées pour
sa 22e édition les saveurs du potager du
roi les jardiniers du site ont ainsi
présenté leurs productions aux visiteurs
et transmis leur passion à l'image
d'antoine jacobson le responsable du
potager ce qui me plaît c'est de pouvoir
passer dans le jardin et de dire tiens
là il ya un poivron petit marseillais
faites attention ne goûtait pas les
graines c'est piquant mais la chair
c'est juteux cetc acidulées il ya un
côté un peu pomme ou là un peu plus loin
il ya du chis hausse est une plante
aromatique japonaise
il ya quelque chose peut-être un peu de
cardamome un peu de caen france augmente
la cannelle ses dégoûts quand on
reconnaît pas de chez nous alors là un
peu plus loin vous tombez son dû mais
l'austria c'est quoi ce truc ça
ressemble sa la taille de nos lives
ça ressemble à un mini pastèque ça le
goût d'un concombre acidulées le potager
du roi c'est près de 900 variétés
fruitières et légumières étendu sur plus
de 9 hectares en plein versailles cette
fête du goût et du jardinage a remporté
un grand succès auprès des visiteurs
c'est magnifique je connaissais pas du
tout ce cadre qui effectivement
splendide avec les architectures
derrière le dégoût que je ne connaissais
pas dont je serai pas vous dire le nom
des senteurs extraordinaire et puis
surtout c'est tellement beau plus un
beau soleil
automnale
c'est magnifique c'est versailles quoi
pendant ces deux jours un marché
gourmand a également proposé ces
produits du terroir sans oublier les
fameux fruits et légumes du potager du
roi et c'est la fin de cette édition je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivis je
vous donne rendez vous demain à 18
heures pour une nouvelle édition du
journal en direct je vous souhaite une
très bonne soirée
vous